yeah yeah well you don't pay it so yeah
I know you still just yet I did for love
yeah yeah yeah well we are an unpaid
team over here I think the only person
who gets paid as you because of ticket
numbers for your show yeah and also on
top of pink dick what do you get out of
it George has a nine-to-five he's doing
this because he believes in it and he
thinks that I'm going to tell you how
many met George I met George I was
signed by maker studios okay you guys
know what that is they're owned by
Disney now but day before it was Lisa
Donovan and her husband that started
that boyfriend Danny zap Danny Danny
they were married yeah oh okay [ __ ]
I know I don't know so years ago Lisa
calls me and she goes hey I'm starting
this company called maker I go what is
it she comes to the studios he was at
her apartment in Venice and I go into
the side of our apartment it's like a
green screen in a room or whatever and
I'm like I'm gonna do this it's gonna be
big okay it's okay okay it's not gonna
be big then years later they go come
again but we have a dude new studio this
is when they were on Washington right it
was bigger and then all of a sudden it
just kept getting bigger and then the
next thing you know Lisa's like I'm
selling it to Disney for 500 million
dollars good lord
do you believe that I believe it and I'm
the [ __ ] that goes no no no thank you
so how did you meet George and so when I
was to Lisa when she wanted me to be on
maker I go okay I'll do it and then I
got producers the first person I got was
Mickey right and then I got who Patrick
I remember Patrick and then I got you
because you wanted it George as always
believed in me George has always been
very excited about me he's the only one
in that company that I felt like an
Ricky like true devoted love that's very
unusual very but but the Disney Disney
bought it and then they saying it
because that's a really good thing to
have like a very responsible white man
in your
corner he wields power and also white a
white pink dick look at me right now man
I really appreciate it we appreciate you
George and even the first video that you
put out and how you cut it you know
right out the gate it looks amazing so
good yeah
and I'll never ask to see your dick why
not
maybe one day would you say um you take
eventually but George you do stand-up
now too so I maybe have you do one of my
shows it's gonna happen dude yeah yeah
it's gonna happen soon
do you want to do Bakersfield with me
Saturday I don't know what that is
so a guy old a rich guy in Bakersfield
is paying Bobby I can I disclose the
amount
[Music]